hi i'm sal founder of the khan academy
and i'm kim khan academy's u.s history
fellow and it being july the month of
our nation's birth as well as an
election year kind of a not so exciting
election year we thought we would excite
that we would spice things up a little
bit
by creating a crowdfunding campaign to
sponsor american history and government
content on khan academy the goal is to
answer all the questions you might have
about our history and our government
anything from what's an executive order
to how the supreme court works but to
make it happen we need your support
it'll help you learn but even more it'll
help your fellow citizens learn so that
we can have a deeper richer and more
spirited democracy
so help us make history at khan academy
with our very first crowdfunding
campaign to create education by the
people for the people
so kim you've got a phd in american
history and you create and curate a lot
of our content what are we going to do
as part of this campaign well i think
what's exciting about what we're doing
here is that this is going to be a
easy to understand completely
non-partisan way for people to learn
more about our government and to become
engaged in active citizens very exciting
we're looking to raise three hundred
thousand dollars by july 28th and to put
that in perspective the content we're
going to create is going to have more
information than all of the political
ads combined for a very small fraction
of the cost and shortly after that we're
going to start putting the content up
that kim and i and others create to
answer all of your questions
you can also get some amazing khan
academy swag and perks by backing us
here on indiegogo
we look forward to your support